good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday it's
hump day don't forget to hump someone
how's everyone feeling today I woke up
this morning and I realized it was
Wednesday and I was utterly devastated
this week is it's just better though
crawling back Jackie it could be Tuesday
it could be but like it should be
Thursday night 1,000% but you know what
all good things
they they come they don't come easy you
know okay so just like serve themselves
up on a platter for you Saturday
Saturday I'm doing Queen Souls oh that
tells from John I'm doing Queen verse
Elton John SoulCycle I can't believe
I've been sitting next to you for ten
minutes I didn't realize are you wearing
leggings I am
there's I don't think I've seen you wear
leggings in a minute I feel like I
always wear leggings but I either wear
them with boots or like with something
that doesn't make I don't usually wear
leggings his pants right right right
unless I'm on an airplane or something
or going to the gym but I don't know
these are Spanx leggings too they were
just like giving me all this confidence
okay I love it
you know what I mean um yeah no I know
totally no you mean we're gonna be
covering Housewives of OC and we
promised we would do deer toasters which
I totally forgot about until right now
right so we will pick some litter yes
but just some updates we did our poll
about cam toes oh yeah well ming-lee
people want us to put them on sale in
January so stay tuned for that we will
have updates about some information
about cam toe site leading up to it but
all you need to know right now is that
is Memorial Day Week in 2020 and it's
gonna be the best weekend of your life
in the Poconos in the Poconos it's gonna
be good times y'all good freakin we're
gonna turn them stones for sure oh you a
joke on arrival everyone gets a stone
well there's like plenty of stones on
the premises which is why we chose it
because it's obviously like something
that's important for us so everyone
there will be stoned for all Shoni vibes
for sure Tony vibes only you'll be able
to turn them like you can have like a
pet stone whatever you're feeling yeah
it's gonna be good also but you can't
get stone you can get your own stone
this Friday at the Turning Stone Casino
where I'll be performing
feel free to get tickets Eric rolled my
job calm its we run in New York upstate
and your Syracuse can't wait to see you
guys it's gonna be a great time it's
gonna be a great time anyways we have
such good stories today complex dynamic
we were just talking about how the
beginning of this week was quite
lackluster in terms of events yes and
also I I blame the TPG Awards because
they just took everything
they stripped me bare yeah of anything I
had to give so I'm feeling better like
perkier now and we've got a great show
for you oh I meant to tell you so I
watched I caught up on the new season of
shark tank on Hulu um thanks Liz Hite I
used your Hulu account
tell your sister Madison I say hi and I
had lots of thoughts I saw the KITT
Renta kit whatever that thing was called
no KITT KITT lender KITT lender and I I
was getting so frustrated because pretty
much everyone went out on that idea
because they thought it was such a good
idea but didn't want to invest like the
manpower into like you've did invest a
lot of money in inventory in order to
make it work I'm like it's just he had
the best idea he was the first in the
space to do it but like a Rent the
Runway could copy him and like it was
just really frustrating to see them like
really give up on him well yeah you know
what I mean no totally it's like oh your
idea is too good too many people want it
we're out you know it was so silly so
silly also like we talked about Kate
letting her on the show before and I
guess whoever does their social as a
toaster oh [ __ ] yes because they reached
out and so if we ever need anything for
her so means and the guy was such a hero
you know like you know Laurie's I got
she doesn't want a zero she wants a hero
he was such a hero like when he got all
choked up about his recovery like now
he's sober like I was getting choked up
like he was such a it was such a success
story like I don't know why they didn't
invest I mean did you see the hsm not in
instance no but now I watch Shark Tank
through the lens of ageism and it's so
apparent and it's almost I don't even
know if it's ageism but it's definitely
like it I think that they film for such
long hours that sometimes they're just
in bad moods because they're so rude to
people sometimes oh for no reason oh but
sorry the reason I brought this up is
that girl from America's Next Top Model
yeah um Lisa did something what did she
do she had like this kids thing it might
not have been the season because now
that I'm thinking about it then I went
to CNBC and was watching reruns but it
looked like it was very very new because
you could always tell when the episodes
are old episodes are new I think even
the Sharks got afraid she was on
America's Next Top Model and she also
won America's next top metal all-star
her name was Lisa and she had like a
super sad story and she had this like
kids thing that was like a rubber like
bib that you eat food in and it was like
such a bad idea and she like would not
take no for an answer and she ended up
getting a deal I mean that's the way to
be either
to be is like your idea can stink but as
long as you like bully someone into
giving you a deal
they appreciate I make a deal that's
like risk proof for them like you get
paid back and you have as much money as
you need
yes very interesting yeah um well I'm
glad that you're seeing the truth I just
love watching shark tank I actually feel
like watching it before bed and then I
wake up and do the toast and like it's
2:00 and they say it in because last
season was their tenth year anniversary
and every episode they opened like shark
tank ten years ago ignited the
entrepreneurial spirit of America and
it's so [ __ ] true and I feel inspired
by shark tank and I just like um I just
I think watching it before bed is like
more people should do it cuz they'll
wake up on a weekday and just like find
that entrepreneurial spirit inside them
yeah motivated you all could use a
little more motivation especially this
time of year is time two strikes on
totally Anna Ronnie said R Us said it
best
maybe he'll only be your motivation oh
yeah
that's actually a great song oh it's
also listening this morning about it he
unkind words you said Madame Armada I
didn't say unkind word what I said I
still stand by she's the next beyoncé
and still even to say she hasn't
released an album yeah okay so it's a
what's all this hype and now I heard the
song motivation I saw her performance
she's still she's so impressive but now
I still what is the hype from let's put
that she was but to put that crap too
bad I have a bigger series that maybe
the fourth out of fifth least relevant
person in in fifth harmony at the time I
have a bigger gripe that the Beyonce of
the next generation went on Dancing with
the Stars and didn't win oh normani
yeah yeah well like she's the best
dancer of our time she went on dancing
at masari's which is unfair and didn't
even win so the show's unfair yeah I
mean when you think of Dancing with the
Stars as it relates to fifth harmony
it's wildly fascinating seeing as how
like Ally Brooke just went on and lost
and some people take Dancing with the
Stars and they use it as a climb up yeah
and some people use it on their way down
as like a clutch clutching onto some
sort of relevancy or it's just like a
peekaboo I'm so i right I'm going back
to my hole so with Ally Brooke I think
it was definitely like a clutching thing
and it's just so weird to think about
where all the girls landed like Camila
Kibeho
yes okay she did get to see a six month
a head start on her solo career because
she was one who left first but at the
end of the day like all the girls pretty
much left
equal and what she's accomplished versus
what other Pete
was just so astonishing like she's now
on her second year being nominated for
Grammys yeah
it's crazy it is crazy there honestly
all so talented like they should start a
band together Lee
I mean 5th harm if you were an OG
harmonizer back when they were called
Delilah's and they were on x-factor a
really never made sense that Camilla was
in the band because she was so just and
I don't think that now but back when
they were kids like she was the one who
had the most stage presence she was the
most vocally talented and everyone
cheered the loudest when she would sing
and they would give her all the solos
and I remember Mark Anthony when he was
a guest judge the first time you ever
heard her sing like he couldn't believe
it like she was never really made to be
in a band she kind of slipped through
the cracks of x-factor and ended up just
being like thrown into a band so the
band was like doomed from the start
because she was always too big for the
band yeah but the band here so people
like Norma always won Harry Styles which
we'll get to yeah there's always one
Justin Timberlake Nick Carter yeah but
you know what Backstreet Boys has been
able to stay it would stand the test of
time even though they seemingly have a
star you know usually it's like that one
star is what breaks the group down
because people get jealous and then one
person is getting all the attention
Josie in the Pussycat Dolls remember
they just went to be Josie but I just
see like Little Mix has found a way you
make it you know 25 percent across the
board
oh so the most interesting factoid is
that Little Mix is my artist of the
decade on Spotify by the way that's the
least shocking thing ever really I know
I never of Little Mix they have released
over the last five years like literally
just kept really seeing good songs that
like you want to listen to a lot they
don't go number one but it's out of
frequency that you're always listening
to it I don't think that's shocking I
was I was really shocked oh my god I saw
this honey where do you see that uh your
Spotify rapped your artists of the deck
i screen shot at all of mine but I maybe
haven't seen my artists a decade well
confusing when it transitioned from year
to decade you I'm gonna help you no it's
okay it's okay I'm gonna scroll up I
thought that death that data was just so
interesting so interesting there was a
funny tweak on fire about someone who
was like oh my god this spotify crap
stuff it's like so true and someone's
like yeah it's true it's literally you
data okay so your top songs of 2019
uniquely yours by the way I think my top
songs of 2018 was such a great album I
mean it's always the best playlist ever
when you got your top songs I want to
know my top song of the decade sorry
excuse me ma'am here in 2019 my sound
changed with the seasons yeah yeah yeah
my lucky artists number one was Taylor
Swift but is that the decade no keep
going
dad top artists Taylor Swift going world
citizen I would say one half of this
little sideshow talking about podcast
the morning shows obviously oh here what
is it the music that defined my decade
bangers by Miley Cyrus we can't stop but
that's not about me my artists of the
decade Taylor Swift well the things
we've seen considering she wasn't on
Spotify for the whole decade you know
right that's true oh wait actually no
I'm sorry oh I'm sorry no no I skipped
through wait not shocking at all guess
uh John Mayer okay I thought that's what
it was gonna be but no okay I'm gonna
give you a clue Oh charades okay ready
two words first word first syllable no
first listen the first word this is the
first word line one direction yeah
that's not talking to me at all because
like I have been a Lundy sand-like
and I still now even though they're not
together me that were just like such
British band fans oh my god we are so UK
amazing that actually is pretty nuts
very cool I am you know talk about on
the show that I would love to just
mention it's not I don't think it's big
enough first story but did you see the
major flop that was liam payne's album
release I saw the smallest thing about
it about what if these songs being
controversial so the fandom has really
like turned on him and the reviews are
really bad like the reviews basically
say it's a bunch of like pop songs put
together there's no fluidity there's no
continuity but there's a couple lyrics
in random songs and he's had this before
where he likes sexualizes bisexual women
yeah ah and fandom is like really not
happy with him so it's really sad that
like his debut solo album it's like a
huge flop yeah well she won't get to in
our first story oh my god I'm so jazzed
about are you ready to get into it
because now I think that it's time we've
had two good segues you know it's
definitely time so it's time for the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and it's for sure
time and I just want Harry Styles to see
like the best version I mean when we
got his story cuz obviously you know
it's like a huge turkey Falls managed to
ram and the best version of me is the
version that's keeping up with her new
yes new Miss a habit changing solution
that helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses it is based in
psychology noone can teach you why you
do the things that you do and arms you
with the tools to break the bad habits
and replace them with better ones it's
cognitive behavioral approach but
honestly it just works it's not a diet
Noom is a healthy and easy to stick to
way of life no food on numa's considered
good bad or off-limits they teach
moderation and can be used in
conjunction with many preexisting
popular diets if you want I think the
coolest thing is that we've been talking
about this for awhile I download a new
like almost a year ago
definitely check in and out which is
okay with it it's like I fall off it's
fine Noom lets you come back new him
understand that you're a human being but
I have now been on it like really
strictly and it's because I went to the
doctor and she was just like as she
weighed me and like oh my god and she
was just like asking me if I use any
like calorie counting apps or like diet
tracking up something honestly no and
she was like grid I don't really
recommend them but if you're going to
download I think Noom is the best one
out there and it's the only one that I
really stand by and when she said it I
was like did you use neucom slash toes
shows so I get was we should be going
around telling nutritionist about our
chrome okay yeah oh my god that'd be a
great way to boost business yeah so
you're human if you go off track on new
there's absolutely no shaming it's just
tips to help you get back on track
tomorrow well you can chat with a goal
specialist and your new community to get
and give help to people going through
the same thing um you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
make a big progress sign up for your
child today at noon calm slash dose
that's Noom n-o-o-o m.com slash toast
what do you have to lose you guys visit
new mom slash toast start your trial
today that is new mom slash toast the
Laos last weight loss program you'll
ever need
sign-on feel amazing also a little hack
I think for resolutions is to start your
resolutions like not on January 1st but
a little bit before so that on time
you're a first year and you feel like
you're in a better place and that your
goals are like more on the horizon and
like starting a diet or anything new on
January 1st like feels so cliche that
you know you're not gonna stick to it
yeah so January 1st is national hangover
day so yeah I don't know how any and
then I'm January I never feel anywhere
and you at the beginning of the year you
know so if you have something in motion
already it can help you stick to it a
body in motion stays in motion ok let's
get to our first story because kendall
Jenner and Harry Styles played spill
your guts or affiliate rats on James
Corden's Late Show which is called some
version of late with James Weir Late
Late Show with James Corden which Harry
Styles is filling in for all week I got
to pick his own guest and I found it was
really shocking that he had kendall
Jenner seeing us out they used to date
they sedate it was the most premium
content I'd ever seen in my life oh look
I've the video was 9 minutes I never
wanted this game to it Harry Styles is
the perfect coat like a grill in for
James Corden one because to me they
sound exactly like and two because he is
comic he is a star he's a comedian he is
so personable and relatable and you know
he is very private and I feel like
there's so many rumors about him and his
dating life but he's really whatever he
does do press like he opens up like I
hate when people are private and then
they do press just don't do press you're
obviously a private person right except
for the fact that he didn't answer one
of the questions I know but it was still
like sometimes his non answer was or an
answer like the SEC worth that kendall
Jenner said the word zayn he took a bite
of that scorpion of course so the way
that it went was obviously you've all
seen spill your guts spill your guts you
either answer the question or you eat
something truly Biola is like Fear
Factor so I own bull penis
they had cow sperm they had a salmon
smoothie they had a thousand smoothie
like that looks like something that'd be
serve you know at the Beverly Hills
Hotel
exactly they had a thousand-year-old egg
nog they had a scorpion it was so
disgusting it was so disgusting you
think like obviously answer whatever
question you got I don't want to eat
that baby there's no question like such
a great premise for a game by Elias so
the first question Harry ask Kendall to
rank her siblings as from best to worst
parents and Kendall actually did it and
I was shocked I thought for sure Rob was
gonna be last okay no I mean obviously
she put Rob first that was like a Kris
Jenner PR movie I don't do I think Rob's
a bad parent no no is he the best out of
the five absolutely not that was just
like a nice like she threw him a bone
because if he's not first he would have
been left right and no one's even I
honestly forgot that I was a parent was
part of this question so he could go at
the beginning or the end it doesn't
matter then when you get down to the
Nitty Gritty it goes Chloe Kim Kylie
Kourt
and you know that Kendall is like pretty
much the only sister who really like
rides or dies for Courtney um so the
fact that she said party was last was so
shocking and I feel like you could say a
lot of things to Courtney but she will
get most offended at that like there's a
large chance that Kourtney and Kendall
are not to be gay well here's the thing
she said they're all amazing parents and
that's you know your ranking is the best
of the best but like you're ranking them
amongst each other so like for Courtney
to hear the cheese or his parents and
like Kim yeah it's just interesting it's
interesting but also I feel like and
this is gonna be like I'm not a mom so I
can't you know say what makes a good mom
or not but it's definitely easier to be
like a more hands-on involved mom when
you have one kid who's gonna say this is
happening three or four or five so I
feel like Chloe being number one like
like duh like she's one angel angelic
child she does have five rats Cole came
with Kylie right but they really are
such amazing parents and even Courtney
for all the [ __ ] that we gave her like I
think she's an amazing mind by no means
- I think she's a great mom it's her
priority her kids are always been her
heart if she was the first one to be a
mom I think that she like is when you're
the first in the family like you're the
guinea pig almost like yeah you test so
I think they're great great parents for
sure let's see what you want about the
Kardashians like they love their [ __ ]
kids and I think they set a great
example for other for like everyone who
looks up to them to be like good parents
and their kids are really well-behaved
except for the time with a nanny yeah
and I just I think they're they're great
see that was a great question great
question
I'm glad Kendall answered it also she
looked so incredibly beautiful oh my god
the backbone he's clavicle and her arms
were like so toned and perfect I just
didn't know where to look no I know and
like her face too like her father I
don't stand Kendall like as in the car
but I was standing she held herself with
Grace and she was still funny and she is
like a cool she's like a combination of
being an actual supermodel but I think
like low-key she like doesn't like to
wear makeup and she's like a tomboy
almost and I think that really came
through like she's a really cool good
personality but she's also literally
sending the highest-paid supermodel in
the world like how can you be both you
can you can
so then Kendall asked Harry um which of
the songs on his album are about her
he's for his previous album and this is
what kind of really shook me about the
whole thing because when Kendall was
announced as the gasps like people
thought it was weird to say dated book
they did when they were teenagers so it
was like that one picture of them making
out on the yacht like I don't think it
was a greatest love story ever told but
then it turns out cuz Harry like Larry
squealed in his chair and didn't answer
the question it turned out that some
songs were about candle so I'm like
maybe this was the greatest love story
ever told
I don't know and watching them together
I was like I don't understand why I
couldn't work no they're perfect for
each other
perfect for each other but I was really
and I still now am more confused than
ever like what their relationship was
because as a consumer we heard that they
were dating and then there were pictures
of them on the yacht paparazzi and she
was sitting on him like straddling him
kissing and it was like the most amazing
time of my life but then it's like they
never really like we're seeing after
that and it really seemed like a fling
like they never addressed it like when
you think of Kendall's like great loves
like you don't think of Harry when you
think about the girls how is he like you
forget about Kendall like they were
teenagers but years later he's writing
songs about him about her on his debut
album like there definitely was more to
the story I don't know I feel like
actually there's not a song about her oh
and that's why he didn't want to answer
yeah he was putting on a little bit like
I think I mean honestly lame to say
there's no song about you rather than
Burton whatever lame it's rude yeah yeah
no it's like not so she was like I've
been wondering yeah no and it just like
takes away and then also people could
think he was lying so I think he just
like acted like oh my you are totally
right there are no songs about her yes
I'm here because it's more often
embarrassing to admit that there's not
because she was sitting there like also
like his album seems boring like he
wants to be interesting what's about who
let me go reaction was so genuine like
when he put his hand in his face I think
he's like a talent and I'm not saying he
was like lying or right I think like he
can act though yeah he was really sunny
he was in Dublin Mo's that movie called
oh yeah your favorite with david dobrik
what's the coldest war of the world it's
one word with a D no John Kirk
do I'm gonna yak such as yes so like I
think he was playing like he was hamming
it up who's being coy yeah oh my god now
that you opened my eyes to the fact that
he totally has no song on his album
enter like it makes me feel so bad first
she's like sitting there like thinking
like I've been wondering for years like
as many songs about me and like none oh
my god chug Jaggi that's so funny okay
then Harry
as Kendall who is the most unlikable
supermodel and though Kendall had the
answer on the tip of her tongue she did
not spill I understand why she didn't
spill it's like it's business you know I
know but I would have [ __ ] loved it
honestly I care more about the question
she didn't answer about who slid into
her deems more than I give a [ __ ] about
which models me and spoiler alert
they're all [ __ ] okay yeah but like
she's friends with most of them so right
the one that she's not friends with is
she friends with Cara Delevingne yes big
time
she's friends with Gigi she's friends
with Bella is she friends with Joan
small yeah I guess they must not be that
big of a model Carly class
oh but I feel like they're Oh the Taylor
Swift well I don't know I don't know
yeah yeah interesting cuz like who else
is the biggest supermodel in the world
that that would have crossed paths with
Kendall I feel like and they chose not
to be friends right I just feel like
honestly Carly Clausen Kendall or like
in such different places in their lives
like yeah that's why they wouldn't be
friends
I'm just saying something to think about
if anyone can like dig up some tea let
us know so then Kendall asked Harry if
he's ever seen an episode of Keeping Up
with Kardashians which was such an easy
question he said yeah you guys were all
eating salads in the kitchen yelling at
each other and then she said oh so you
seen every episode yeah what a great
little moment for pop culture
enthusiasts around the world a hundred
percent then Harry asked Kendall um
who's the most surprising celebrity
that's led into her DMS and she really
considered telling us and she had an
answer and honestly like but that was my
only issue with the whole thing like she
should have said it she should have said
it like it's cute I'm letting you think
it is unless the person's married right
which I don't think that's what it was
she should have said it yeah it could've
been anyone
yeah I'm sure was like Leonardo DiCaprio
right like really cute and then Kendall
s Harry to rank his One Direction former
bandmates
albums their solo careers like rank them
and before she can even finish a
sentence he ate the scorpion yeah the
second year does it he ate it but like
they were eating and then spitting out
yeah but I mean would you even take a
bite of a scorpion no I was thinking
though I would have taken the whipped
cream from the bug parfait and just like
licked it yeah but that wasn't even an
option for well it would have been for
me but they choose what you're writing I
can't play like I could never play this
game
to the question for me they would have
to put a radish out like that would be
the craziest thing Kody you know you
would just have to answer the questions
yeah would you say the most unlikable
person that you've met in your course
Hilary Duff okay are you ready for our
next story that I just found so interest
on I just want to say like kudos to
whoever's idea it was like to put these
two people together on this game Harry's
doing such a great job he's filling in
all week so I think we'll have more
content hopefully some more viral moment
I'm really looking forward it was so
well done Bravo it was so enjoyable if
you haven't watched it you should watch
it even though our recap because like
the cuteness between them it must be the
chemistry is palpable palpable okay next
story so interesting because Chrissy
Teigen just answered a bunch of
questions about being a celebrity she
does a Q&A on Twitter where she's like
open enrollment anyone asked me a
question about being a celebrity and
there were some really interesting
answers just about the logistical of a
logistical moment yes me like questions
like do you set an alarm or does someone
gently wake you up so true um do you
have a million rooms in your house okay
okay but there's 50 questions so I'm
gonna go through the best one the best
ones but John sets an alarm and then
leaves it in the bathroom while he makes
the kid's pancakes so she has to get up
to turn it over but she doesn't have
like an assistant who wakes her up who
wakes her up do you have a million rooms
in your house and how many expensive
dresses have you worn she said every
room is very used and occupied I've worn
a lot of expensive things but always
have to give them back right since the
babies I'm not sample size anymore so I
buy almost everything I wear and then
resell on the real real and donate the
money to charity oh my god I love her
yeah do do you pay restaurants money to
let you cut the line or do they just do
it automatically
good questions are incredible she said I
make reservations and don't give them
the option to say no quote hi it's
Chrissy Teigen and to make a reservation
for two for John Legend do you have any
availability if you just say hi can I
make a reservation for two they say no
you got to say it all at once got it
interesting how this was the most
interesting one how the Frick do most
celebrities travel on planes are you
ever just hustling through the airport
trying to make it to your gate on time
no they escort you there is a terminal a
mile from the airport that you pay
membership for they do the same security
privately and take
to the plane in a car oh it's yeah but
they don't have that everywhere they
must have it they obviously have it at
LAX do they have it they call like they
have it at New York yeah
I don't think they do because I have
flown LAX to JFK and seen many
celebrities and in New York I always see
them standing like [ __ ] like waiting
in line like everyone else and in LA
they just show up interesting I'm sure
some not obviously not every airport has
it but I'm sure a decent amount yeah I'm
sure those four celebrities like if
diplomats are flying you know right
where there's just important people do
you do your own Christmas shopping and
grocery shopping or does an assistant do
it
assistant does a lot but it's funny when
it's the assistants birthday and you got
to do it yourself
when was the last time you heard the
subway / public transit she said maybe
10 years or so I her a lot though
okay that's relatable yeah when you're
watching TV and you see yourself in a
commercial do you register it as hey
it's me or does it feel like another
person she said I say why did I wear
that or why did they cut that so much do
celebrities talk to each other only
through assistants yeah like if you
wanted to text a celeb friend do you do
it or do their people talk to your
people she said sometimes I ask a
publicist for someone's info to text but
for the most part I don't talk to many
people because I don't want them to
think I'm a thirsty weirdo how do your
kids react when they see you on TV they
could not care less what is the perk you
feel most guilty about money oh I'll
take it off your hand she said I
honestly want to know what celebrities
do about phone numbers do you all change
them every month how do you make sure no
one get gets your number or gives out
your number yeah she said a lot of
people change often but mine has been
the same for a long time she said the
question do you read gossip about other
celebrities or text them about stuff you
hear hmm she said yes but no one really
reads their own [ __ ] and you don't want
to bring people down unless it's a big
garbage story then you reach out to see
if they're okay yeah yeah um this is
fascinating keep going someone said is
it hard to make friends who aren't in
the entertainment industry she said a
lot of my best friends are people I met
on the creative side my managers and
agents in hair and makeup people I'm
very close with but I also have best
friends me or it could make fun of me
all the time and it's great mm-hmm she's
so humble yeah how hard is it for you to
go in public say to eat order to a movie
and not be bothered she
said I go maybe once a month or less
only if I worked earlier and have my
hair and makeup done already right
um do you miss being able to go out in
public without fans asking for pics and
talking to you this was the best answer
ever
she said no if anything I wish they
asked sooner instead of it being super
weird for a while right right we're
sitting through the whole meal no like
not that when someone comes up to you
and they're talking to you and they're
scared to ask for a picture so kind of
drags out longer it's like as for that
picture like right away because they're
dragging out and then I
I've been in that position I never want
to say do you want a picture cuz I feel
like that's kind of great but it's like
get after your picture no but it's also
like if you're at a restaurant and you
know someone's staring at you for so
long and then they'll take an hour and
then decide you to test for a picture
it's almost better just to get it out of
the way 100% when I see like not to make
this about me but when I see like
someone's staring at me and I don't know
that it's cause like their toaster ofan
like I'm like why you searing Roux
didn't you learn right no no no and it's
we're in an interesting precarious
situation because like some people know
we are but like most people don't yeah
so it's like if you're Syrian me it's
like what's your [ __ ] problem it's
Christy Teegan like no one's staring at
her right and doesn't know or they don't
know she is there sharing her because
she's like a literally a supermodel it
she's me right like I mean if you don't
know she is like she's a force because
she's tall and stunning right what's the
process like when you decide to vacation
somewhere security where you say etc she
said depends some places are notorious
for beach photos and I'm super paranoid
but there's nothing that can be done
even if you have security some resorts
call photons it sucks but whatever it's
looks yeah sucks
how do your assistants become your
assistant so you can't stay at a hotel
when you're Christian you got to rent a
house like you can't have that many
people knowing where you are I guess but
some I don't know I think she can stay
at a hotel some hotels are super private
some how do your assistants become your
assistants is it through an agency that
trains people to be an a-list
celebrities assistant or there should be
an agency if there's not she said we
find people that have worked for agents
they're usually completely over working
for agents yeah that's actually a good
point
how boring our award shows unbelievably
boring and you are pulled in 100
different directions and yelled at to
sit down the bar is never close to you
and everyone is so mean to seat fillers
I don't know why anyone wants to do it
oh my god this is so fascinating so
fascinating I thought for sure that they
would be like long and drawn-out but I
didn't think she would say that they
were boring right
and like the seat fillers the street
fill I mean the the dynamic of a seat
filler like it's just we there should be
a documentary at Sunday that's like the
life of the seat filler a hundred
percent if you weren't famous what would
you be doing right now teacher probably
PK pre-k or a stay-at-home mommy cute
what is the absolute one thing you wish
people wouldn't do when they meet you
tell me a story about eight years ago
where asked if I remember a certain uh
oh that's so funny yeah um our most
celebrities nicer or meaner than they
appear to be in public the bigger the
celeb the nicer I've met a lot of
borderline people who had super
attitudes lol but also a lot of shitty
big celebs so I guess there's no clear
path here yeah but I definitely see
people who are like on the rise being
like way more [ __ ] ish then like
people who are huge stars yeah do you
have a house payment or do you just pay
for it all at once she obviously bought
her house to cash his payments she had a
mortgage I don't know about mortgage but
like she doesn't pay it all up front so
she needs a mortgage oh my god that's
crazy yeah I thought totally celebs just
like give twelve Mills cash you know
yeah like why would you if you don't
have to write um some questions about
paparazzi are those red carpet
interviews as chaotic as they seem going
down the line and doing like quick prior
interviews seem so intense no you start
to know and have relationships with a
lot of people I can't wait to meet you
Chrissy yeah totally informal
relationship and I used to do them so I
feel for them it is not easy it is not
easy no it's not
do you know celebs with secret Twitter
and Instagram accounts she said yes duh
do celebrities get each other gifts for
her birthday Christmas holiday presents
she said yes and then I send thank-you
flowers and then they send thank you for
the flowers flowers and then I said
thank you for the thank you for the
thank you for the flowers being a
celebrity is basically just like sending
people flowers yeah do celebrities worry
about paying their own bills like the
light mortgage internet or do they just
get their assistants to do their
business manager I have a business
accountant who handles everything and
sends me summaries of my spending slash
income I don't get mail interesting not
even like spam catalogs I guess not
that's so crazy
do your assistants live with you or do
they go home at night they go home we
have a house manager who works at the
house all day to handle our lives in day
to day busy
his packages scheduling for a household
staff etc but so that person lives in
the house I guess so that's crazy what
the [ __ ] is a gifting suite a huge room
of [ __ ] her publicist bring their
clients to take pictures with each piece
of [ __ ]
that's so money do you ever get asked do
you ever ask to be booked on a show it's
example watch what happens live she said
there were some shows that used to be
impossible for me to get booked on we
would beg I won't name them now why not
um yeah but she could definitely like
waltz on to watch outside whenever she
wants oh for sure watch happens live but
like I wonder what other shows you know
yeah like Ellen who knows yeah maybe
that's what she's talking about um how
do you hire nannies do they stay with
you 24/7 or other multiples she said we
have four incredible people not all at
once one will rotate and stay through
the night oh my god that's crazy
they've two kids four nannies um change
after becoming famous is presumed to be
further worse
have you changed for the better since
becoming a celebrity she said whoa very
good question I don't know honestly I
still see things from every perspective
but I'm also highly anxious and
perceptive so it's kind of hell for my
own mind
but also good I like that I can help
people but my own self is kind of stuck
yeah
very interesting and then I'm this was
the most interesting one do you ever
just sit and think like damn look at my
life and just think about the fact that
you're famous
you have loads of famous friends and
just think about your life and the fact
that you're famous yeah she said lol no
I sit around thinking I sit around
thinking how everyone hates me and is
mad at me and how I'm about to be
canceled oh my god welcome to the world
Chris YouTube welcome to the club okay
if you guys wanna I'm gonna go it is by
the way what an interesting concept for
Q and I it's like honestly cute people
do q and A's all the time now like he
used to be like special like a reddit a
ask me anything now it's like every
[ __ ] influencer and their q and a's
that having a theme to the QA and the
theme being like what's it like to be
famous is so wildly interesting I always
wonder about so many logistics and
honestly becoming a very like small legs
ela celebrity has like giving me the
answer some of these questions but I'll
really never understand like what it's
really like to be like a mag like a
bonafide like superstar like what the
day-to-day is like yeah the logistics
it's so interesting her answers were so
good she really I know everyone says his
manner but she really is so relatable
yeah and she like for a while made me
hate the word relatable it's a good lady
Ellen but she is like I relate hard and
what's so like cool about her she's
obviously a huge she's a celebrity
person like a list etc but then like
she's married to John who's really like
you know cream of the crop right he got
and so she has every single experience
under her belt right and she gets to
choose what she wants to do like she
hosts that lip-syncing show I think just
because she likes it yeah you know yeah
that's really fun it does it's a great
job but she doesn't really host it you
just answer yeah she just gets like
dance and look beautiful must be nice
seems like a dream okay I just get to
dance and look beautiful to like just by
being every day here on the show yeah
and I'm looking even more beautiful ever
since I started subscribing to Birchbox
I just say someone got Margo a gift one
of her her friends like as a gift got
her a year's subscription to Birchbox
like a few years ago and I thought it
was like such an interesting cool gift
and now that we started work with them
I'm on like my fourth Birchbox and I
have to say like it is revolution I was
like you think like a subscription box
I'll just like throw some crap no I've
gotten such good stuff everyone keeps
asking me on tour about how my hair is
so shiny and I use literally this travel
sized thing it's Herman Oren Co it's a
polishing gel serum that I got in my
Birchbox and then I got my new Birchbox
and it was like laying out on my counter
and this mascara was in there and I got
was getting my makeup done and
coordinating my makeup artists she was
like where'd you get this mascara
um I guess where my Birchbox she's like
literally this is like the new new it
mascara I'm getting it product I never I
didn't I didn't realize it was the new
it no I haven't tried yet Courtney said
it's gold right yeah Courtney said it's
like v-shaped oh my god that's so
excited interesting what I love about
Birchbox is that one it can nature due
to the new products that can [ __ ]
change your life or in Co and if the
products like isn't something that you
want to buy full size of you just throw
it in your travele thing and now you I
literally have a travel sized item for
any of my beauty needs when I'm on
vacation you never know what's gonna
come up with am I gonna look like I got
electrocuted like your help or my poor
is gonna be enormous we need help okay
so the Birchbox goal is to be the beauty
and grooming shorcut they want to make
the best use of your limited time and
give you an efficient effective and
enjoyable way to test drive new products
more importantly they want to give the
opportunity to take some much-needed you
time your Birchbox is the perfect
monthly where my
to do just that the majority of the
population knows that even just a few
minutes of you time can make the world
of difference almost half of you guys
feel like you really have time for
yourselves each day each month you'll
get a birch box it's a reminder that you
deserve time would you take a moment to
care for yourself and to make whatever
time you have for your beauty and
grooming routine even if it's five
minutes or less a moment about and about
you and for you it is a monthly box of
beauty and grooming samples that are
personalized to your beauty and grooming
profile making it easier for you to
discover products that are right there
for you for many it can be intimidating
to walk into a huge beauty store and be
faced with an overwhelming amount of
choices or you just don't have the time
with Birchbox you can get curated deluxe
sized samples that you can try on at
your own pace in the comfort of your own
home when you find something you love
you can buy it full size on Birchbox
calm it is delivered right to your door
it's convenient and something to look
forward to getting in the mail every
month it's like sending yourself a
surprise gift surprise gift for just $15
now I know that really sounds corny and
normally I would have read this in
rolled my eyes but it actually is like
really fun and surprising to like get a
box every month with like beautiful
things that like make you feel beautiful
that are targeted towards you and I feel
like they really nail like what I want
and like that whole on like corny
element I'm just like it's a gift for
you no it actually really is and also
giving it as a gift is really kind of
consider it like when someone got that
for Margo I was like that's such a
creative cute idea and they've tons of
variety of products you fill out your
beauty and grooming profile it's very
easy answer questions about your skin
and hair type preferences and life style
they will take your profile into account
when creating your box every month so
that you know that there are products
chosen especially just for you so we
don't actually get the same stuff but we
both got that mascara they also let you
customize part of your box just in case
you don't want a total surprise
the Birchbox online feature online shop
features products for more than 500
prestigious brands like tart wander
Beauty keels Sunday Riley or BAE Wow
rich and Mac so have a nice orb a little
thing can't wait to vacation oh I didn't
get orb a [ __ ]
today only Birchbox is bringing their
cyber monday deal you can get 15% off
$30 plus any any order of $30 or put any
order of $30 or more 20% off $50 or more
and I'm sorry I said that totally wrong
you can get 15% off any order of $30 or
more or 20% off $50 or more order and
25% off 75
five dollars or more no code needed head
to Birchbox dot-com /t empty and start
shopping if you're listening head over
to Birchbox comm / TMT and start
shopping or you can use the code toast
20 for 20 percent off Birchbox gifts
subscriptions head to Birchbox comm /
TMT and the code is toast
20 sign-on like have an easy time
looking strange products looking sick
it's really such a fun thing I just got
my new one in the mail and it's like
it's a gift from me to me it's a gift
for me to me and I do like getting my
items as a surprise I know you were all
curious if I choose them or if I get a
surprise because it's like I said it's a
gift from me to me Birchbox calm flush
TMT use the code toast 20 get it for
yourself get it as a gift do what you
got to do this - both okay
next story lizzo stands by her song
revealing outfit at Lakers game quote
criticism has no effect on me as I'm
sure we have all seen Liz O War a song
revealing al she wore just like a dress
with a big hole in the ass yes like Mean
Girls style but in the booty right and
then she was having the time of her life
at the Lakers game now she's receiving
criticism so she took to Instagram live
to let us know how she feels about the
criticism she said Who I am in the
essence of me and the things that I
choose to do as a grown-ass woman can
inspire you to do the same you don't
have to be like me you need to be like
you and never let anybody stop you or
shame you from being yourself like this
is who I've always been
now everyone's looking at it and your
criticism can just remain your criticism
negative criticism has no stake in my
life no control over my life over my
emotions I'm the happiest I've ever been
I'm surrounded by love so you know I
stand liz' 100% Isis tis oh um I did
feel like when she responded to the
criticism she wasn't actually hearing
the criticism because what the criticism
was saying was like we love you like you
are so yourself but like time and
there's a time and place for everything
and I don't know it's like a basketball
game where kids are at I was like the
perfect place to like show your ass um
and she didn't really get that I think
she was probably like listening to the
1% of people who were like saying
negative things about her body and it's
like that's not where I think people
like we're actually like um shocked by I
think like the shock factor was that
it's a kid
sporting event lots of families like I
don't know if it's the right time in
place to be showing everyone your but
yeah so her her response kind of glazed
over that fact and while I agree with
everything she's saying like be you be
yourself and I love that she's gotten
famous and she hasn't changed who she is
if anything she's empowered to be
herself even more and I love that
message but like that's not really what
we're talking about here you know yeah
there's a lot of different things that
people are saying a lot a lot of
different arguments and people are
saying oh we're talking like what about
the children like cheerleaders are you
know wearing skimpy little outfits like
the players curse and fight and etc and
I love Liz oh I love her so much and
honestly I love this for Liz oh but my
issue is that like Liz Oh does things
and they become trendy and like it's all
girls start going about like start
wearing the shirt with their song
showing like it's inappropriate like
even though there's nothing to be
ashamed of when it comes to your body
parts like you started plays you still
need to like use public nudity is just
oh yeah like it's not something yeah I
mean we should have been embracing and I
also think even though people are saying
she's only getting this criticism
because she's plus-size I think that
it's like Miley Cyrus did several oh my
god like just wore a t-shirt we're just
seeing her ass like it's just
inappropriate and it's like I love this
thirdly so but the thought of people now
Halloween like oh we're just gonna wear
t-shirts whereas she was like I'm sorry
this is still like society you know like
agree we're in the public yeah no I
think that she probably feels like she's
only getting attacked because she's well
sighs and I look at it as a totally like
body neutral person like no it's just
it's just inappropriate like and I'm
sure like if they're like mothers there
with their kids you know it's like it's
just not what you want it's not what you
came to see it does it does has nothing
to do with her body I think that there
would be equal amounts of outrage if it
was a Miley Cyrus or someone else I'm
wearing this to a sporting event I think
people are saying rihanna like shows her
butt or kim's like [ __ ] oh no or on a
red carpet where it's like it's a look
but i think there's a difference between
wearing something like wearing even when
like miley wore her you know booty thing
on the red carpet well she shorted
though they would you would talk so much
right but i mean these kids watched the
VMAs right but wearing something on a
red carpet versus at a sporting event I
think is very different so like when
Rihanna wore that whole outfit that was
like see-through diamonds right I think
it's there were no children there
yeah I I do think it's different and I
don't think it has anything to do with
her being plus I think it just at the
end of the day boils down to there's a
time and a place for everything yeah but
and a lot of people are comparing it to
the dancers who wear the bare minimum
but I think there's a big difference
between like the other way to skin a
skin but there's a difference between
showing like having your butt hang out
on the bottom like you know other way I
just a short short answers the digits
they definitely wear like skimpy or
outfits but they're on TV they can't
they don't wear anything that crazy they
wear a shirt and a bottom like it might
be shorter than some people would like
but they don't wear and I mean I'm only
thinking from the Knicks because I've
been to gameday where it outfits they
were skirts like yeah covered their
small outfits but they cover yeah yeah
it's I will take I it has absolutely
nothing to do with with plus-sized not
plus-size it's just inappropriate yeah
and just like I think Elizabeth can do
whatever she wants but not everyone can
do whatever they write so if everyone
starts dressing like this like it's like
I don't know pendemonium pandemonium
anyways love her next story is so crazy
because walmart has pulled the sweater
of Santa about well we're gonna show you
a picture of the sweater it's a
controversial holiday sweater that
honestly Jackie showed me picture at
first I like didn't know what I was
looking at and then when she pointed out
I was like oh Santa's doing cocaine yep
so take a look for yourself it's
honestly [ __ ] hilarious
it went up on like the Walmart Canada
site and they pulled it they apologized
they said it's a third party seller and
this obviously like doesn't jive with
like Walmart and I see how this could
happen like when you have so many
third-party selling on your website and
also I know there's a minute to see it
yes it just looks like snow you know and
honestly if I didn't read what it was
like I might have looked at it for an
hour not understood right and I totally
see there being like there's definitely
a million companies who's like you know
mission is like crazy it's like tipsy
elves but like x-rated so I totally see
how this happened I don't blame Walmart
it definitely seems like an oversight
and it's honestly pretty funny it's
hilarious and I feel like now this
sweatshirts gonna this sweater is gonna
sell out because it's like the perfect
ugly holiday sweater that's funny and
irreverent and it's something that would
sell on barstool no just like Amazon
tipsy elves like that's so hilarious
it's really funny the fact that it made
it on like a Walmart is hysterical
inappropriate and I'm glad that
but I don't blame Walmart no not at all
I could so see how this could slip
through the cracks because it's pretty
subtle yeah when you see it it's like
when you were shown is only doing one
thing when you were showing it to me I'm
like do they take it down just because
like he looks the Santa himself looks
crazy like he looks like a baseball not
he looks like mr. may never see this is
just like mangled yeah so I'm like oh
maybe it just looks like crackhead Santa
but it's actually Santa doing crack yes
it is crackheads and confirmed confirmed
it's crack to crack on Santa that is
just really hilarious
so um man I do need to get my hands on
one of these though if you uh if anyone
knows where I could get one I know a
couple people who would really enjoy
this okay this and final story a little
more of the year news times person
people I'm very excited people a beer
has been announced TIME's Person of the
Year is Greta Sundberg times Entertainer
of the Year is Liz oh and times business
Person of the Year is Disney CEO Bob
Iger times athlete of the year is the
u.s. women's soccer team
oh and times guardians of the year are
the public servants excuse me
I think it's like the people like
elected officials cute okay um I just
really want to talk about Bob Iger
because we speak about him like probably
quarterly on the show he's like at the
helm of one of the biggest company he's
the CEO of Disney has been for a while
and I feel like CEOs these days are
always like getting pushed out getting
fired and there's always like a
controversy and he's just like the
non-problematic CEO that we need he is
so smart he's a visionary I feel like
everything Disney is doing is like so on
the cusp of like technology and culture
and then have you been getting these
targeted Facebook ads for Masterclass
it's like this new company yes that like
it's you it's almost like a DVD like you
can get you buy a movie and it's like a
master class by you're one of your
favorite CEO so Bob Iger has one Sara
Blakely has one they have athletes
entrepreneur it's like huge stars um
it's actually like an interesting
premise and I wonder if anyone that has
enjoyed it and Bob Iger has won and I've
been getting targeted for the Bob Iger
and they give you like a 30-second like
trailer and it like he looks so smart
and so handsome and I'm just like in
love with Bob Iger Wow and I just know
out there there's a toaster whose dad is
Bob
I just I can't I refuse to live in a
world where Bob Iger doesn't have a
daughter who's a toaster I know I know
I totally agree I think that's a great
choice Suzie plus is really taking the
world by storm II Webster like uh Zack
just got on it last night so I can't
wait to like watch old stuff I think a
lot of these choices are I mean all the
choices are pertinent to the situation I
love that Liz o is the entertainer of
the year because she she entertained me
Entertainer of the Year oh yeah she
entertained me all year I was highly
entertained for 365 days yes and she
looks great on the cover I'm just like
loving the respect she's getting um the
women's soccer team being the athletes
of the air like who else like fight like
they just deserve so much respect also
Megan Rapinoe was the Sports Illustrated
sports our senior year so they're just
getting respect all around I love them I
follow them out like so many of them on
Instagram and I just like I loved that
time you know when like they were
winning and the Erica came together and
rally behind them like I missed that
time no totally but we get to bring it
back like you always for it's so funny
like you forget what happens in a year
like if I work said one guy said I had
to do a year round up I'd be like only
could think of the last month no my mind
is limited to the last two weeks like I
don't remember anything that happened
before December started totally and
Greta Sundberg being Person of the Year
she's the youngest person ever she was
on the cover and you know what I'm
really glad they didn't give her hair
and makeup because that would have been
so inappropriate like I was thinking cuz
she reminds me so much of Millie Bobby
Brown like for some reason like just
growing up so fast in the spotlight um
and have you seen 1 million Bobby Brown
looks like these days I saw a picture of
her speaking at the UN and I really
thought it was like Cindy Crawford like
that's how yeah I'm sure she saw a
picture of her recently and she's I
think how many seen like Rachel Bilson's
yeah she had Brenda Cheetham new blowout
new skin like she looked so different
and like she really scares me like she
is like the essence of like growing up
in Hollywood like way too fast around
older men like it just freaks me out
um so I'm glad that they didn't give
Greta thunderbird cuz she's like an
activist like she can't be out here like
she is serious and I'm glad that they
didn't give her like a blowout because
it just would have been inappropriate
and that's not what she stands for so
when I saw her on the cover with her
regular hair and face I was like you go
Greta yeah and it was like cleany vibes
cover Oh beautiful cover very beautiful
really you know it's highlighting the
beauty of our the earth that we aren't
currently destroying exactly I totally
understood the metaphor a beautiful
stuff so that's pretty cool even though
I feel like we've been reporting on like
times people of the year like for the
last month
I guess there's so many [ __ ] lists
there none of which we're a catalyst and
then it's like there's time there's
forbs there's like they're Sports
Illustrated and there's Maxim there's so
many [ __ ] lists like you think with a
little bored with all these lists we'd
be on one you know at least yeah but
what actually this morning did they're
artists of the year Billy Eilish artist
of the decade Taylor Swift something
cameo got something no it's really
what's gonna be really interesting is
who wins the Grammy for Best New Artist
because I feel like Liz oh and Billy
Eilish are each winning they're
nominated for the same like new artist
categories they're each winning 50% you
know everything and like that's the big
one
it's but you know it'll be a statement
like what the Grammys is so like snobby
and they have their like nose up to
everyone like I don't it's just like
it's what whoever they choose like I
don't know I'll be I'll be shocked like
right I'll be shocked either way like
honestly I'd be shocked if they give it
to Billy Eilish like giving in to like
teenage morality but I'll be shocked
could they give it to Liz Oh to someone
who's quote-unquote different you know
cuz they're so snobbish
yeah obviously I want Liz so to him
because like I consumed her more than I
can assume Billy Eilish but I have the
utmost respect for Billy Eilish so I
respect for Billy Eilish but like I I
just think it's like a horse that go
race and they're really just like
neck-and-neck and is there everyone at I
know but like this is the time Vera time
right I just think it's gonna be really
interesting and people aren't realizing
these two these how it is yeah who are
up against each other and we're gonna
have to choose it you know I I hate to
do it to be honest they need the woman
from bring it on to come out to the
Grammys and be like had in second place
they do they do need that she's iconic
we should get her on the show we would
love to okay we're gonna recap Real
Housewives of Orange County and we are
going to do dear toasters reminder dear
toasters it's our advice segment you can
email us to your toasters at gmail.com
and I just want to let everyone know
that our recap of real houses of Orange
County is brought to you by first leaf
pairing wine during the holidays isn't
just about food it's also baked partner
perfect partnership actually perfect
partnership
pairing wine during the holidays isn't
just about food it's also about having
the perfect wine for gatherings and
traditions that we love maybe some
family functions
you just gotta endure you definitely
need first leave which is why
we always have the incredible wine on
hand the season thanks to our first
sleep subscription we are ready to
spread holiday cheer for every occasion
as you guys know firstly it was a wine
subscription service it helps you you
know it takes the intimidation out of
picking wine because they have a
customized wine club that curates wine
selections tailored exactly to your
taste preference they're on a mission to
know you better than you know yourself
start by taking a simple quiz to
pinpoint the ones that you like then
firstly if we will create a custom pack
of six wines based on your answers
delivered straight to your door
they're so confident that you'll love
every bottle that they have a 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you receive
wine you don't like they will cover the
cost each shipment arrives you will
taste and rate the wines online firstly
it applies your feedback to refine
future boxes whether you prefer
something sweet or bold firstly it will
get will fill your season with joy all
season long because they only send one
send you wines that you love I find
wanting to be incredibly intimidating
I'm like I know I like white wine that
doesn't taste bad and I don't really
know how to say that at a restaurant and
I also don't like you know a
particularly expensive wine so the quiz
hanging in the comfort of your own home
it's like it removes the shame and also
it's a quiz for dummies it's like yeah
do you like good or bad red or yellow
like super yellow ok watered down yeah
it's just really simple and you're
actually surprised how the quiz can kind
of analyze your taste buds so well
because we got we're on like our like
8th month and pretty much all the wine
is gone oh and I love having people over
not having to run out and get wine like
because while carrying those heavy bag
maybe I'm not drinking like I know
there's always Olivia comes over like I
always need wine Marco comes over like
there's always someone who needs wine
and doing the first leaf subscription
like ensure that you always have six
bottles in your house once a month it's
pretty it's pretty genius
tis the season to drink and be merry
celebrate the holidays within an
introductory first leaf subscription
that includes six bottles of wine
shipping is totally free go to try first
leaf dot-com slash toast that six
bottles of wine plus free shipping at
try first leaf dot-com slash toast it's
a great gift for someone for the
holidays or gift for yourself check it
out a try first leaf calm slash toast
sign on get drunk in the comfort of your
own home having a good time with some
good
Real Housewives of Orange County we
wrapped up the trip and abruptly yeah I
was like we are we going back to our I
thought I might have fast forwarded
through the commercials too far because
it was like they were having a dinner
cruise and then we're back in the OC
what a weird trip like what a low-budget
trip that return that rinky-dink boat
that they had quote-unquote dinner on
was so and there were other people on it
it was so lowbrow I was will this whole
trip was like really a [ __ ] show but
then they got back and they were talking
on how much she loves Key West yeah
because they were like drunk the entire
time yeah it's always a good time so
Vicki didn't end up actually breaking
her no but honestly that fall was
painful to watch her over and over like
so painful this I immediately thought
she had to have broken her leg me too
and when you wouldn't when the episode
started and they all woke up in bed she
had a boot on but he took a temporary
boot it wasn't real it was it was crazy
the episode was crazy
I'm trying to like gather my thoughts
they went on the cruise Kelly was very
calm I'm just kidding michio and her and
Tamra made up and I know that right now
they're not in a good place but I kind
of I just do want Shannon and I do want
Tamra to like understand Kelly and I
feel like there's so many
double-standard it's like it's
borderline unfair that it's obvious why
they're not friends but I was happy to
see her in Tamra makeup in the moment me
too I'd live like a humble Kelly Dodd
right and I and I love that she didn't
blow up at Vicki she was just like
obviously we're not gonna make up right
now her anger is very managed and I
think it's totally worn to however the
anger manager said something very
interesting word and he said like you
know in order to conquer fear it's not
to avoid it it's right in front it's so
avoiding avoiding avoiding Vicki like
isn't what's gonna get you through it
yeah and I thought it was like mean that
everyone was making fun of her and Emily
for doing anger management but they
spent a lot of like usually they'll film
for 10 seconds like they sent a good
chunk of the episode filming the session
and I found it to be quite healing and I
thought Emily really um like have some
demons and I was surprised and and happy
that she was so open about it a hundred
percent and I thought the anger manager
like did a very good job
he gave them some advice like actually
things that they can do like see Jolie
and
like if I ever wanted to go to anger
management like I would totally trust
that guy
no 1,000% on the beach in the ocean
something just really made a calm and I
believed it and usually think like
people doing like NeNe Leakes on Atlanta
is like seeing a life coach right now
and it's like total [ __ ] because
she's still being so nasty to everyone
um but I thought it was kind of like
empowering like I believed it
momentarily yes and now I feel like
everyone has the patrols that they need
to go to Vicki's engagement party yeah
um Shannon's boyfriend is so cute and I
just love Shannon being happy like she
was like hysterically laughing talking
about babe like they weren't just so
cute oh the babe wouldn't they told the
story about babe like it was the worst
story ever more fun but she was really
cute about it and in every episode she's
more and more the snacks are like she
the weight is just falling off snatch
allure like her legs are so tiny she is
tiny and she's so happy that's what it
is like she was the same but in every
episode but she's just really Khloe like
from within and now that she could wear
a hat that says divorced AF while
sitting on a boat in Key West where her
husband's start an affair like that is
the level of empowered I hope to be in
2020 a hundred percent and I'm really
like honestly I know there's so much
going on but like I'm really spending
this season about see like being Emily
Simpson's champion like and I feel like
some women are opening up to her and
like they gave her the Hat that said she
was fun and like that made her feel good
you know I'm just like I think there's
so much more to Emily and we haven't
been able to get past it because she's
been getting like bogged down with
[ __ ] um and I just I'm happy yes I
understand because as someone who has
found herself being Gina Kirsch in
hiders you know that's just like not
what I saw for myself by 2020 um and I
think it's perfect because like I think
their friendship is so underrated I yeah
that Miss people are so underrated and
you know what they're so different it's
actually shocking that they would be
friends because honestly Jeana lives in
la-la land and emily has like a very
firm grip on reality honestly a little
too firm she could take a trip to LA the
land it would do her some good
so I find it shocking that they don't go
at each other's throats all the time
because as Emily I would kind of be
frustrated with Jeana just sitting there
like no Matt would never cheat on me
again like daddy [ __ ] would [ __ ]
she's like already got it let some
people learn then it's like it is what
it is but I really like I like Jeana I
don't know sometimes that like an
amazing Jeana impersonation yeah that
was really gloss over that no I I like
her I think she's funny like in her end
using stuff I can't get with her like
she's just too thirsty for three amigos
like attention and love and she keeps
meeting like I'm gonna hang back it's
like we know you're hanging out with
Vicki like relax and the math stuff is
so uninteresting to me Oh totally
especially cuz it's a man we've never
met
yes that's what it is it's like you
can't expect us to care so much about
someone we've never met like we're not
we you dating a new guy versus you
nating matt is the same to us because we
don't know them right right and what her
mom was saying about not knowing that
was so crazy Shady it's like your your
daughter has a husband of 10 years with
a bunch of kids and you don't know him
that likes crazy
the [ __ ] that was crazy and it seems
like her parents are in the yo seat all
the time so like they should know him
yeah but they also just moved to the OC
I don't know also it's clear that Jeana
and not like aren't together in present
times because she has a boyfriend and we
reported a story where he was like
saying how much she made because they're
in court right now yeah yeah yeah and
she is dating dr. hottie cute yeah cute
it's really crazy to watch Kelly and
Brian knowing that she's gay when else
right now I was thinking the same thing
last night like she moves quick and
honestly she upgraded Rick is hotter
like then and even though I like Brian
because I he tells it like it is to her
like he doesn't appreciate Kelly for the
reasons that makes her so incredibly
crazy Kelly like she's really hysterical
and I was laughing so much during the
episode when Shannon and Tamra we're
going parasailing like parasailing is
very very very scary like even as
someone who like loves to be like a
daredevil like you're up the length of a
football field like it's super high up
and it was I was hysterically laughing
that angle of a GoPro is just like so
unflattering remember Nicole from
bachelor in paradise got that angle too
when she would say yeah having a GoPro
be up your nose is so empowering I was
hysterically laughing also Jeana like
crying that whole scene when they were
doing the water sports was very funny
very very funny parasailing man like
it's so scary I never never do it again
no I did it once I felt like Shannon it
say I really do like to experience most
things once like not bungee jumping or
coming out of a plane but like
parasailing then ski like just anything
jumping off like the rocks somewhere but
um I don't need to parasail again no I
did it twice once as a child which
actually it was more scary as an adult
of course you realized really like the
limits like as a kid you're like a big
follow them in the water like no if you
fall [ __ ] your jam got a broken leg
yeah best it's it's just
for me um I also really want to quickly
talk about real houses of Atlanta
because I have to tell you what happened
and I just think that you will find it
so fascinating so Marlo um held an event
where she is um starting a wig line and
honestly doesn't relie make a lot of
sense because she's known for having
like crazy like trashy ass wigs like
never fit her right like people are
always making fun of her wigs like it is
a weird flat exploit whatever all the
women showed up to support except Kenya
because Kenya like has a competing hair
care company and she just like didn't
want to be there and also Kenya is so
[ __ ] petty and rude that like she just
didn't want to be there Eva wasn't there
because Eva and Kenya are just Eva and
Marlo are just not getting along so in
the middle of the event they're playing
this really fun game where Marlo's
hosting she keeps picking housewives to
do wig styling and they both have like
10 seconds to do a flatiron curl and
whoever does it better like wins it's
like a cute fun game and in the middle
of the game a marching band comes in
holding Kenya Moore hair care products
and Kenya Moore is there bailing you
know your edges it's your edges matter
that's the slogan and she's like your
edges matter and it was so rude it was
the most shocking thing I've ever seen
and Marlo handled it like a pro she was
like yes my edges do matter Julie who
she was like put some of the press stuff
on me she was being so much her I was
shocked she didn't flip a [ __ ] lid
like I would have died and then it all
calmed down in Kenya was just like being
at the party and all the women were like
surrounding Kenya at the bar and Marlo
was trying to play this game and so she
was like can you come over like you play
next and Kenny was like no I don't want
to play a game and she was just like
taking all the women away from the game
and like that's when Marlo snapped and
honestly I told a great she had security
escort Kenya out it was like so is it
all right bad enough you're gonna
interrupt my thing but like now you're
cheating everyone away from like the the
game and the wig like it was just so
frustrating and I totally understood why
that set her off and I'm surprised she
wasn't set off in the beginning so
called security but then Kenny wouldn't
leave and then she eventually left it
was just like it was one of the most
fucked-up things I've like ever seen and
I cannot believe Marlo didn't like fly
off the handle
yeah and that's how Marlo with Sam yeah
that's [ __ ] insane it was insane like
with the tea she had the two-person
marching band it was like kind of like
Mohsen Margene and I don't know but they
have like a full drum it was really
[ __ ] loud but it was a two-person
marching band oh wow very sad yeah let's
get miss you to your toasters let's do
it dear toasters our advice segment feel
free to email us anything we always keep
anonymous dear toasters at gmail.com
this one is titled [ __ ] a coach
Claudia and Jackie I just graduated from
college and got a job teaching middle
school I teach seventh grade and even
though I didn't know what on earth I was
going to do after college I've
absolutely fall in love with it fallen
in love with this job from the beginning
of the year I've had a flirtation with a
coach in my school who also does
graduated from college that sounds so
fun we are the same age we have a
similar sense of humor so is a natural
thing he would walk down my hallway on
purpose or come check on my class just
to talk to me he also spent his lunch
break in the cafeteria flirting with me
this has been going on since August but
students had mentioned he had a
girlfriend so the whole thing stayed
really innocent pretty much every
student thought we were dating and made
jokes about it until but nothing
happened until the day before
Thanksgiving break when he asked her my
phone number and asked me to hang out I
said yes assuming if there had been a
girlfriend they had broken up and on the
Tuesday of Thanksgiving we got drinks it
went so well we were out for four hours
and then made out in my car afterwards
things started heating up but I stopped
it and left things continued normally he
went to a wedding that next weekend and
I didn't hear for him for two days but
assumed it was just because he had was
with his friends and was busy Monday
morning he comes into my room and flirty
tech he comes into my room so flirty
text me all day long and makes plans to
hang out he comes over Thursday after
the basketball game he coached after
texting and flirting all weekend and we
have sex he's Ben's the night and it's
just perfect never awkward it's so
normal so easy I get to school on Friday
morning and the teacher works
I worked super closely shows me these
photos of him and his girlfriend all of
her facebook from the wedding and the
weekend before which she posted
Wednesday night aka the day before we
hooked up and he was commenting on all
these photos I immediately text him
because while we never had conversations
about exes our being exclusive I
certainly didn't expect him to be
someone he used to cheat he denied
everything made me feel stupid and crazy
for asking manipulated me into thinking
it was all my fault and then text me at
3 a.m. tells me we moved too fast and
need to be friends like no [ __ ] loser
you have a girlfriend it ends it all
ends with him saying he needs to give me
context of the situation at some point
but he had a death in the family on
Sunday I think he made that whole thing
up and he will let me know when he can
talk I haven't heard a word from him
since
ever since every time I've seen him in
the hall he literally runs the other way
like a coward I just feel so so stupid
for falling for his [ __ ] and thinking he
was a good guy he obviously is a
complete piece of [ __ ] but where do I
can move forward how do I handle work
how do I deal with this pit I have for
this poor girlfriend who has absolutely
no idea I feel awful and I wanted to
kill my kids
and I want to kill my kids now when they
make jokes about me dating hello God I
don't know how to handle the campers I
don't know how to handle any of this at
work and also it makes me wonder how
many of my middle school teachers were
[ __ ] please give me some advice on
how to deal with this sincerely [ __ ]
and [ __ ] over by that's not true if
you ever think about like we're teachers
ever [ __ ] okay but like where we
enter middle school like all the
teachers were like ninety-seven they
can't even like you put get get a boner
if they wanted to but right okay I feel
two ways about this on the one hand you
know an easy thing for me to say is run
for the hills
ignore goodbye not your problem on the
other hand I'm so inspired by the
beginning of this story that I'm tempted
to say it sounded so cute like this
could this could be a love story and I
know cheating is terrible but it's a
girlfriend it's not a wife so just like
and maybe it's just timing is bad like
know but also like the way that he
handled it like really put the nail in
the coffin for me right it's not good
him manipulating you and making you feel
stupid but I don't I don't like any of
that but I just want to give him the
benefit of the doubt for one second and
say like maybe you don't know you never
know what's going on with the girlfriend
maybe the death and the family let's
pretend he was telling the truth was on
the girlfriend side and she can't go
through a breakup right now so he's
gonna do what you need to do and he
loves you and he's not gonna let you get
away but he also is not gonna be a bad
guy and break up with his girlfriend who
just experienced a death so he's trying
to finish I'm not saying that this is it
but like have you ever seen the movie
he's just not that into like sometimes
this that's not this he's not a loser
the whole mentality of like sometimes
it's like not that complicated like
sometimes he just like had a girlfriend
and wanted to get [ __ ] you know like
that most likely he has a girlfriend and
just like thought this girl was cute he
definitely might have like liked her and
just wanted to get have sex and she fell
for it and sometimes it's just as
complicated and as simple as that yes
and that's my first like that was my
first thing to say is maybe a cap and I
don't know like the coach it's so cute
the campers they're invested like I kind
of want I kind of want to give this you
know everything that you've got and not
just like cut and run which is probably
the wisest thing to do because I'm sure
maybe at the end of the day he is this
scumbag but maybe he's not excuse me oh
yeah he probably is I just think you
know if if history has taught us
anything this guy is the rule not the
exception you know yes people are saying
they love my optimism but now yeah
okay next one is called it's just keep
us posted and like don't break it to the
cameras they can't handle it my
husband's grandma
is evil in the past three dear toasters
in the past three years I've put on
about 50 pounds or so and lost about 30
of it on Kido case using my husband's
grandma thinks it's okay to constantly
comment on my weight and watches what I
eat when you go out with her for dinner
about every week or every other week
it's because sorry I was reading common
sense sorry I was distracted and I
really like need to be fully focused on
these I'll start from you thank you in
the past three years I put on about 50
pounds or so but I've lost 30 of it on
Kido my husband's grandma thinks it's
okay to constantly comment on my weight
and watches what I eat we go out with
her for dinner about every week or every
other week I took a week break from
Quito and decided to get a pizza for
dinner last week cut to this week my
husband's grandma says to me are you
gonna be a good girl to speak and get a
salad my jaw literally hit the floor I
was gossiping about it with my
mother-in-law it's my husband's paternal
grandfather so she was talking about it
with her husband's mom you know so it's
not the mom's grandma it's the dad's
grandma this whole scenario I teach 7eb
said it's justin timberlake and a bad
teacher
I never saw a bad teacher I know I know
you know it's like you know what's your
favorite movie in it I just have no I
think she just like wrote us the script
writing us okay are gonna be gonna be
able speaking get a salad my jaw
literally hit the floor I was got some
gossiping about it with my mother-in-law
and she thinks that my husband needs to
call her and tell her that she needs to
stop do I tell my husband to call his
grandma he kind of tells me to ignore it
but I don't want to keep going to dinner
with her because she's constantly saying
crazy rude [ __ ] to me like comparing me
to my skinny 85 pound sister-in-law and
telling me that I'll never be as skinny
as her or asking me if I'm pregnant
while staring at my belly like damn
aren't grandma supposed to bake cookies
signed me taking a big-ass bite of my
big beets pie yeah I feel two ways about
this cuz like while you should totally
see how two ways you know I'm such like
a bipartisan little [ __ ] like well you
should always like confront and like
sweet you stand up for yourself like
with grandparents like there's like a
level of like you just have to ignore
like be like their minds are obviously
like deteriorating and it's like you
just have to like have like that level
of respect where like you just sit there
like and it's terrible because what you
should always stand up for yourself and
you shouldn't let anyone talk down to
you that rule is like kind of exempt
from grandparents just because like
there are in their old age and they
don't have like that's social aware and
it's like you just like kind of have to
sit there and take it if you do and if
this is if it were me
I would not have anything anyone say
something to the grandma because
obviously like she's a hardcore [ __ ]
and her being spoken to was only gonna
make her [ __ ] hear and be like oh like
you couldn't take it yet have your
mother called me so if it were me I
wouldn't say anything to anyone I would
sit there and take it but this is a lady
who I think respects bitchiness and I am
so about respecting our elders and so I
think for the boy but you don't say
anything but I think you can give it
back to her a little bit you know and I
think she would actually respect it you
know what I mean
like I don't know her like not saying
that you should be calling her fat or
anything but you can give it to her a
little bit I think it like yeah I saw
some pics of you in the 70 screen yeah
I'm have a cookie all the ones that you
didn't eat yeah you know like the ones I
could manage yeah maybe she would
respect you more like not if you were
like a [ __ ] and had your husband called
like honestly that's [ __ ] like yeah
maybe she wouldn't respect you more if
you like gave it to her a little bit you
know yeah just get like a little digs
here and there I think she would respect
it and she'd be like oh this girl can
hold her own maybe I'll calm down but
for the most part just tune it out it
doesn't matter and respect your elders
okay dear toasters my boyfriend and I
have been together for a little over a
year now we just moved in together our
relationship is pretty much rock solid
and I feel like we have all the bases
covered we're super attracted to each
other we're best friends we make each
other laugh we'll get into occasional
fights like any other couple does but
for the most part I've always considered
us really healthy and lucky and it looks
like you could really be my forever
person you get the picture as I
mentioned we just moved in together and
I've been in an unpacking organizing
frenzy trying to make the place perfect
and feel like home while my boyfriend
was at work I was working from home
unpacking boxes I came across a shoe box
with a bunch of old birthday cards and
stuff like that no more than ten cards
one from his mom one from his dad a few
from me so I was like aw sweet he keeps
these then I found one that I didn't
recognize with hearts all over the
outside now I normally I'm not a Snooper
I know everyone says that but I've never
ever once gone through his phone or
anything like that I hate the chitin
besides I've never felt the need to this
kind of literally fell into my lap and I
need to know and I know the girl who
it's from she's actually one of my good
girlfriends who he took up with years
ago before he and I ever became romantic
she naturally opened the card it was a
Valentine's Day card from her maybe 2016
really cute and heartfelt note inside
but that's not at all not that's not all
it also contained a mini envelope with
nude Polaroids so naturally I'm sorry I
know this was years ago before he
I were ever together but I find a number
of things bothering me here one I'm
still friends with this girl and so is
he they kill still keep in touch
sometimes harmless DMS which will openly
send in front of me and stuff like that
but I hadn't ever felt threatened or
that bothered by it since she lives
across the country isn't a very happy
and healthy relationship of her own but
now it's bothering me too bothering me
too
now it wasn't bothering me at first
right now it's bothering me second thing
that's bothering her is that he's been
holding on to these for three is years
through two apartments including this
most recent one into a home that we now
share why the [ __ ] would you hold on to
these nudes and a card like this from
anyone other than your girl your
girlfriend who you are moving in with
three third thing that's bothering her
there were so few cards in there that it
feels like a conscious decision to keep
that one specifically maybe you just
doesn't get a lot of cards many
birthdays and holidays past in between
where he could have had those cards as
well so what the [ __ ] do I do now I
already took the card out of the box
grabbed a pair of scissors cut that [ __ ]
into pieces and throw down the trash
chute my first instinct was to say
nothing at all I doubt he will notice
it's gone and if he does slush if he
does or says anything then he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but I know myself and I'm not sure I can
let this go without saying anything I
just don't want him to try to turn it
around on me and accuse me of snooping I
hate finding myself in this situation
please help I'm annoyed this girl
honestly sounds like she's like her head
on really straight he's really Shane
honestly I feel like she's doing
anything that everything that I would do
and I've gone through a whole range of
emotions from the beginning of like it's
okay like it's cute to keep mementos and
blah blah blah - now I think you guys
have to break up because I just don't
know how you can nail this and like
knowing that he without telling him that
he can't ever talk to her again but then
you sound crazy
I'm not saying that you actually have to
break up but like this is not this is
not an ideal situation but you know what
it sounds like and you really believe
that you guys have like a really good
foundation and a really healthy
relationship that I think you can and
should tell him and just be like because
the odds are that it's totally innocent
I mean it is you can accept the card
isn't what's weird to me like honestly
like like love letters are sweet and
they're like moments in time and I don't
think it's that crazy that he kept the
letter obviously them being like nude
photos in there like it's what makes it
like kind of crazy I know but it's like
why he's a guy why would he throw away
those photos yeah I mean I just think
you got to ask him because if there's
something there there then you should
know and if there's nothing there then
you've nothing to worry about
yeah I don't think there's any
there and I'm sure at the end of the day
you don't have anything to worry about
but it's gonna eat at you and it's
eating at me and it's gonna affect how
you treat him so like on the one hand
you should say something but on the
other hand just destroying them it's
like how long does it take him to notice
how often was he going and checking this
way so I think that you should I was
gonna say like if he doesn't notice that
the pictures are there they never meant
anything but if he does know its meaning
like he'll go in and whack one off to
that Polaroid every in a couple months
like then you'll know that they meant
something right and it's like what kind
of you know like oh my god I have such a
good idea okay you should take your own
nude Polaroids we replace and replace
them honestly that's really so that if
he ever does find it he'll know how cute
funny and sexy you are yeah I think
that's a great idea I think that's a
good idea too but then he'll also know
that you snooped in like if he really
was feeling some type of way about those
new it's like he might get mad I don't
know this is just like a terrible
situation for you to be in I don't I'm
into you honestly I don't I on the one
hand I don't know what I would do
because I like the advice that I would
give you is different than what I would
do because I think I would have to burn
our apartment down if I found that it's
just annoying to think that like this
whole time you were thinking like it was
just like a harmless hookup three years
ago but like now like you see wrote a
letter like you see things different
than like and I think you like you know
that for the past few years you've been
thinking something incorrectly like
that's upsetting and there's a like a
very big difference between like having
a nude photo on your phone versus like
keeping them in a shoebox with parents
with cards from your parents totally
it's weird it's crazy I really I'm glad
that I chose this one because I would
love an update here like truly like I
would say your name but homegirl hit me
up with an update yeah it's tough
because it's like he thinks why would he
ever throw them away like he has I just
had a thought he is awesome new Jackie I
just had a thought of the first dear
toasters we did what if the girlfriend
the coach's girlfriend is a toaster and
she's singing my boyfriend is a high
school coach and we went to a wedding on
Thanksgiving well we just solved your
problems thank you guys for writing in
as always please email us we keep it
anonymous to your toasters at gmail.com
we love you guys thank you so much for
hanging out with us today in the morning
Tosa millennial Morning Show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching this on youtube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up we
are also available as a podcast pretty
much anywhere podcast can be finds sound
set Spotify iTunes stitcher public radio
I Heart Radio class but I have a pitch
for these emojis all the
apps so subscribe leave a review of five
stars about how stunning skinny and
smart we are we love you so much we will
see you tomorrow Xiomara y'all peace out
you